[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno a tutti
io intanto sono emozionatissimo sono
contentissimo di essere qua per noi è
sempre un po difficile noi come street
artist avvicinarsi al pubblico proprio
per quello lavoriamo quasi sempre ad
altezze diverse quindi sui muri sulle
gallerie sulle nostre sui nostri studi
quindi prepariamo le opere d'arte tutto
quanto facciamo sempre un po fatica a
relazionarsi il giorno il mondo d'oggi
ci ha dato una mano a livello social
arrivare alle persone e la questo qua mi
è servito molto anche a me
per riuscire a sorpassare quei muri che
avevo da bambino e quindi riuscire a
relazionarmi con le persone quindi
parlare tutto quanto poi dopo quando mi
lascio andare vedrete anche voi che sono
abbastanza faccio abbastanza il burlone
un po è un mio scudo diciamo è un po è
anche perché mi piace parlare con le
persone come uomo di strada come vostro
amico come il ragazzo a fianco che vi
racconta la sua storia io non ho nessun
problema a dire che da ragazzino
uno di questi miei muri io quando sono
venuti in studio a me l'han nicolò e mi
hanno fatto questa proposta ho accettato
subito perché avevo sentito parlare di
muro però non aveva né ancora capito che
i muri erano da abbattere e io sono
abituato di solito colorarli no invece
questa volta qua ho detto cosa che
faccio io di solito li colora di colori
con loro però ho pensato anche che per
arrivare dove sono arrivato
intanto mando avanti un pochettino di
foto dei miei lavori che così magari chi
non mi conosce
adesso mi racconterà un attimo però vede
un attimo quei lavori che vado a fare e
allora ho detto bob io penso che per
arrivare a fare questo lavoro
riuscire a vivere d'arte sia una cosa
molto difficile da ragazzino
vorrei fare l'artista si va a lavorare e
normale e logico la gente non può
concepire una cosa del genere io ho
iniziato molto presto a essere una
persona particolare a 11 anni
io avrei voluto avere una preside come
la della signora di questa mattina il
mio preside invece mentre a tornare a
casa perché avevo la cresta e andavo a
scuola in skateboard e invece io da quel
periodo la ho iniziato a frequentare
quello che erano le banche che le banche
era un sito dove si andava e c'erano i
ragazzi che facevano breakdance e
ragazzi che andavano skateboard e
ragazzi che iniziavano a graffitari a
gravitare di per com'era all'inizio
essere brighter quindi illegalmente di
notte si andava sui treni si coloravano
i treni state che mondo vanti il che
così allora cosa succedeva
l'arte iniziava a prendere il
sopravvento sulla gioventù quindi non
era solo giocare a pallone cosa che
vivono a me non è mai interessata ove
stessi per forza alla moda io mi vestivo
molto stravagante su quanto per quello
che più volte che noi chiamavano i
genitori a scuola dicendoli quale il
ragazzo ha dei problemi e questi sono i
problemi in ragazza dei problemi è
strano si e disegna tanto
ok si isola che entra nel suo mondo e si
veste particolarmente che non va bene
tutte queste cose qua che ok ero anche
un po un asino a scuola non dico di no
però
mia madre è stata sempre la prima dirmi
alberto perché io mi chiamo alberto mio
vero nome alberto alberto tu sei un
artista tu per me farei l'artista tu non
occorre to impegnati quello che riesci
ok però apri la tua mente sonia
emozionati e io questo conservato di
fare sempre di più
siamo davanti questo è stato qua uno dei
muri che ho dovuto abbattere un altro
muro che ho dovuto buttare giù è stato
poi dopo successivamente quando io ho
scelto di intraprendere questo lavoro e
iniziare a lavorare sui muri quindi
lavorando sui muri
mi sono trovato davanti a delle
situazioni dove le persone non capivano
ci pensavano ancora come banda gli
imbrattatori e non vedevano quello che
era il filone artistico qui è poi
esploso che è la street art e la street
art in questo momento lavora a l'art
basel miami quindi sulla più grande e
fiera dell'arte con i più grandi
galleristi galleristi ci contattano per
avere le nostre opere perché la street
art non è solo murales ma è anche
arrivare alla gente dentro le case
proprio quindi con i quadri con le
stampe con tutto quanto quello la che è
un materiale che farò vedere anche dopo
collaborando con delle aziende in un
modo intelligente
ok che allora arriviamo un po
dappertutto
la street art e inizia a prendere il
sopravvento iniziamo a abbattere questi
muri qua dell'ignoranza artistica quindi
anche noi arriviamo con un livello
parecchio alto parlo di noi perché è
giusto chiamarlo un movimento ok in
questo momento ce ne sono sempre di più
chiunque anche non acculturata
artisticamente sui suoi social alla foto
di un muro perché ormai le vediamo per
la strada quest'acqua è una
collaborazione che ho fatto un altro
artista quindi nascono anche queste
collaborazioni quindi nasce anche
relazionarsi con altri artisti dire
e tu non sei più bravo di me io lo sono
più bravo di te ci mettiamo lo stesso
piano e facciamo un opera insieme
ok sto qua è anche il muro che abbiamo
fatto a berlino quei ragazzi del ted è
stata bellissima anche questa esperienza
qua di arrivare la una città come
berlino che ti dà la possibilità di
poter lavorare
ok il giorno dopo so che è no giorno
dopo dopo due giorni qualcuno è andato
sopra questo lavoro qua però la loro ti
dicono noi ti diamo esposizione dei muri
quei muri la voi potete colorarli quanto
volete
e logico che poi dopo succede che
qualcuno ci va sopra o cosa e quindi non
sarà per sempre però intanto hai fatto
la tua foto e fatto il tuo lavoro ti sei
divertito
ok giovani possa iniziare a lavorare
anche su questo e divertirsi con che
cos'hai a ok e divertirsi con queste
opere e tutto quanto
poi dopo diciamo con l'andare avanti nel
tempo ho iniziato anch'io a crescere
artisticamente e trovarmi di fronte a
dei festival settate il festival e
street art e sono quei festival quelli
un po più importanti diciamo dove
chiamano i migliori artisti i migliori
artisti tra i più grandi artisti e la
ritrovi a lavorare in un modo
progettuale e anche non dico che ti
metti in
paragone con altri artisti però ognuno
deve dare il massimo del lavoro infatti
adesso vi faccio vedere questo qua è un
lavoro che ho fatto
su questo festival molto bello e
importante interessante e qua il muro
mio da abbattere è stato quello là di
trovarmi davanti a un muro così grande e
quindi le proporzioni e come lavorarci
tutto quanto è assieme a degli artisti
che artisticamente sono tra i più grossi
in italia e riconosciuti in tutto il
mondo allora io d'acqua cos'è che ormai
sono quattro anni quasi quattro anni che
ha mollato il mio ex lavoro che facevo
da 25 anni li ho iniziato molto presto a
lavorare qui stato 14 anni perché una
volta se non eri un
un genio o andarvi a lavorare o la tua
famiglia magari faceva anche dei
grandissimi sacrifici anche troppo
grandi a volte quindi dovevi residenti
conto se essere un cretino e far fare
dei sacrifici dei genitori che magari
non riuscivi tua rispettare
oppure decidere di andare a lavorare ho
iniziato a lavorare ho iniziato a
lavorare che avevo perso quindi sui 15
anni e ho iniziato a fare il
parrucchiere non farli fare il
parrucchiere ho fatto il parrucchiere
per 25 anni nel durante o sono diventato
autore arte cosa direttore artistico di
accademia di padova dove abito sono
diventato giurato nazionale di
acconciatura in più
nel frattempo suonavo con una band con
una belle che ho fatto tre dischi fine
ho sempre cercato di trovarmi di fronte
dei muri quindi a delle sfide e portare
avanti quelle emozioni quei sogni quel
desiderio che ho voglia di oltrepassare
ok quindi ho fatto una o diciamo che ho
fatto una band perché ho tirato fuori
degli altri ragazzi che suonavano tutto
quanto e dove lei facciamo sta bene
riusciamo a suonare in giro
facciamo dei concerti ma fatevi consente
anche molto importante e tutto quanto a
un certo punto la band ed un nel durante
io lavoravo sempre il lavoro mi serviva
per e questo lo dico sempre anche quando
vado sulle scuole i ragazzi bisogna
avere una base
ok non nasce nessun artista tu devi
avere una base ok per investire nella
tua passione e questo lavoro qua mi dava
da investire sulla mia passione
prima la musica quella con la musica o
ho smesso
ho iniziato a capire un attimo cosa
volevo fare artisticamente perché mi
mancava quella parte a livello da
compositori al compositore tabelle rho
quindi ogni stato a disegnare
venuto fuori questo soggetto questo
soggetto che mi caratterizza e lo porta
sempre più dietro all'inizio mi dicevano
è ma tu fai serve solo quello allora io
ho iniziato a fare sempre e solo quello
come mi ricorda lo so come vede un van
gogh come vedo un picasso ed è
riconoscibile io ho detto voglio essere
riconoscibile essere riconoscibile vince
è logico che devi sempre avere buone
idee di avere sempre buone idee e non
sempre di fare un bel lavoro e basta
infatti io mi sono trovato un certo
punto dover iniziare a raccontare delle
storie
allora ho detto io posso fare sempre lui
sempre loro sempre i miei soggetti però
è far rientrare in diverse situazioni ok
come noi siamo ognuno diverso dall'altro
non lo possono essere diversi tra di
loro tranquillamente state chiamando
avanti altro video che così ok e loro
possono essere diversi tra di loro
vivere delle situazioni diverse entrare
nei delle fiabe entrare in qualche mondo
magico ok e la iniziato tutto questo il
mio percorso e poetico di sale
arriva arriva
[Musica]
io ho portato materiale per due ore e
mezza perché pensavo di fare e invece mi
toccherà fare veloce tutto quanto però
ci sta ci sta ci sta benissimo ma se vi
faccio vedere questo video poi vi
parlerò dell'ultimo muro che ho
affrontato e non sarà l'ultimo della mia
vita perché ne voglio avere sempre di
più io amo quando anche faccio o dei
festival quando mi come sono lavoro
farmi dare un'idea di quello che
vogliono quindi un tema se hai un tema
allora non è i bozzetti che fai che io
ogni giorno disegno nel mio studio ma è
qualcosa che deve deve essere nuovo e
deve piacere io settimana prossima sono
latina che farò un muro per la giornata
mondiale contro la violenza delle donne
a me queste cose qua mi danno di stimoli
io li vedo come dei muri da oltrepassare
quindi ho scoperto grazie anche al ted
che ci sono molti muri
ancora da saltare gira intorno
scavalcare capito quindi muri come
obiettivi anche no quest'ultimo adesso
lavoro che vi faccio adesso faccio una
cosa veloce guarda tac tac no ok perché
ho poco tempo state che il controllo di
qualità aspetta questo qua cos'è arrivo
è che così bene interagiamo insieme tac
no ok questa una collaborazione che ho
fatto con la ciak roncato quindi la
street art a arriva anche a collaborare
con le aziende
dobbiamo essere noi intelligenti su
questo ok io non voglio diventare
l'artista da cover del telefonino perché
non voglio vendermi perché ho delle
quotazioni con i quadri quindi chi
compra un mio quadro ok e spende 10 mila
euro non può vedere la stessa figura su
un telefonino perché a me non piace
rebbe questa cosa qua allora devi un
attimo capire un ateo come riesci a ben
a venderti tra virgolette questa quale
una collaborazione che ho fatto con la
bmw con ceccato motors di padova dove ho
dipinto l'auto l'auto la vedo come
street
l'auto e street e quindi mi piaceva
anche andare a vandalizzare tra
virgolette un'auto che ha già una sua
linea è molto bella e tutto quanto
poi ho messo questa immagine perché
adesso parlerò di questo discorso
l'ultimo muro ogni minuti 14 sono
fortissimi allora grazie
sono agitatissimo pazzesco stesso tante
volte cosa succede mi trovo davanti a
dei muri che sono immessi che magari chi
me lo commissiona le varie fa essere
tutto quanto mi mandano una foto piccola
da telefonino tutto quanto le misure un
po relativa però mi trovo là davanti un
muro che è doppio il triplo e questa
roba qua non mi agita anzi mi dà una
forza così forte mi dà una forza una
sposina forza una forza così forte che
nel bellissimo da dire una forza così
forte per riuscire a portare a casa il
tuo risultato che è il mio risultato
perché io ogni volta il bozzetto che
faccio anche per un murales gigante
quando hanno pochissimo tempo anche per
un murales gigante il bozzetto che
faccio lo modifico poi manodopera perché
io non sono una macchina perché mi piace
fare questo qua come lavoro ok e mi
piace anche quando smonto dal poi la
piattaforma aerea adesso esco dal
bollino adesso milano su quando svolto
dalla piattaforma
mi piace sorridere e guardarlo e
sorridere quindi emozionarmi
ok l'ultimo muro che è stato il muro più
po più difficile lo dico velocemente
perché mi emotiva molto abbastanza
ok allora questo qua mi ha contattato la
presidentessa del di team for children e
mi ha chiesto ciao tony
conosce di tutto quanto ok ci conosciamo
e mi dice
parlerò un po male nel senso sono molto
veloci perché mi crea molto molta molta
cosa dentro forte no allora mi contatta
mi dice ci vediamo
ci vediamo tutto quanto bara ci
piacerebbe che tu facessi le due
facciate del nuovo reparto di oncologia
pediatrica di padova
allora io gli dico aspetta un attimo due
secondi ci sentiamo perché io sono
sempre stato dentro una campana di vetro
grazie grazie e non però grazie a mia
mamma
ok mi che mi è sempre nascosto le
negative chiave la vita le cose brutte e
tutto quanto mi sono trovato da grande
ok anche se non sono né ancora gr
da grande di fronte a una sfoglia che ho
finito 2 2
ok mi sono trovato di fronte a il
problema ok al problema più grosso
perché io non potendo avere figli
ok mi trovo in una situazione che cazzo
scusate ho detto mamma mia
basta che non mi fa entrare nel reparto
io vengo a farti lavoro te lo regalo io
perché per me non mi costa assolutamente
niente anzi mi mi riempie di di forza
questa cosa qua badola mi fa entrare nel
reparto frutta
conosco questi bambini conosco i
genitori penso che sia una cosa
devastante
infatti chiunque dovrebbe farsi un bel
giretto là dentro che non è la camicia
stropicciata che non è il mal di gola
pastiglietta cosa no chiunque dove farsi
un bel giretto lamentarsi lo riscopre
parlare lui quando il video ve lo faccio
vedere qua il volume
tutto nasce quando abbiamo deciso di
costruire questa timson
noi curiamo i pazienti da 0 a 18 anni è
molto diverso avere a che fare con un
bambino di 2 3 4 anni un ragazzo di 13
14 15 anni a tutto un mondo diverso
[Musica]
è una cosa cui marta teneva moltissimo
avere un posto dove anche gli
adolescenti potevano trovarsi per avere
una specie di ponte tra la chiusura del
lungo metodologia pediatrica è tutta la
vita che era fuori che continuava a
scorrere
[Musica]
non esiste un eroe sessant'anni leroy
deve avere 18 20 anni questi sono dei
grandi eroi che combattono guerre tutti
i giorni e per questo un artista come
noi deve rappresentare la vita è
successo
ho pensato a toni perché questo reparto
dedicato agli adolescenti e gli
adolescenti impazziscono per queste cose
dovevamo comunque
rendere memoria a dei ragazzi che non ci
sono più in effetti questi personaggi
rappresenteranno loro e proteggeranno
gli altri ragazzi che sono qui e che
continueranno il loro percorso
io e sono sempre scappato dalle cose
negative della vita mi sono trovato di
fronte a il problema quindi in questo
momento mi sono sentito di aiutare per
quello che fosse il decreto
[Musica]
le due opere che ora figurato hanno come
motivo principale una scatola di cartone
un involucro molto fragile però dove
possiamo mettere le nostre cose più
preziose e portarla in un mondo migliore
nell'altra con la stessa scatola di
cartone ho fatto un origami e o seduto
uno di questi bambini e l'ho portato a
volare
[Musica]
grazie
[Applauso]
grazie a tutti grazie monti